it's come as such a shock our team were
working on his Easter program yesterday
and in fact at the end of that get
together I got an email last night from
one of them saying we just spoke to Paul
he's really looking forward to it he's
in really good form this was yesterday
and they were due to continue that work
today uh at four o'clock exactly now and
that's preparation for a program which
will never happen and the start of the
series on Boom radio which will also
sadly never happen we knew that clearly
had finished with Radio 2 last year and
therefore he wasn't on the radio and so
many listeners were writing to us saying
I miss Paul O'Grady and isn't that the
nicest thing you can say about any radio
present or any broadcaster I missed them
I missed them coming into my home every
weekend they felt they knew him you can
never really like a broadcaster until
you feel you know them and I think we've
spoken about Paul's character the
courses he care about the dogs Etc his
upbringing he's so giving of his pass
and of himself they felt they knew him
really well and he was when he wasn't
there they were missing their friend and
honestly the feedback we've had today so
many emails